un bout de terre chinois posé sur la mer
plus de 6000 gratte ciel viennent
assombrir le ciel
voici hong kong cette ville ressemble à
un assemblage de jouets pour enfants où
chaque forme représenterait un cube posé
à côté d'un autre
la densité ici est l'une des plus
élevées au monde
dans certains quartiers plus de cent
quarante mille personnes se partagent un
kilomètre carré
une folie pour les uns une économie pour
les plus cyniques
après le départ des britanniques en 1997
la ville s'est ouverte aux chinois du
continent
plusieurs centaines passent la frontière
chaque jour
hong kong et moderne
hong kong est riche
et hong kong fait rêver
mais dans les étages de ces tours les
plus démunis s'entassent dans des
logements tellement exigu qu'on les
surnomme les hommes grenier
imaginez un couloir étroit où se font
face deux rangées de compartiments dans
lesquels on ne tient pas debout
ces hébergements existe depuis les
années 50
à l'époque il était réservé à la main
d'oeuvre immigrée pour une période
provisoire
progressivement ils sont devenus des
logements à part entière cent mille
personnes vivent encore dans s'est
réduit l'histoire que nous allons vous
raconter et celle d'une femme
si l ue qui espère offrir à son fils
saimone une vie meilleure à hong kong
que dans son village en chine c'est
aussi l'histoire de lee joo d'un migrant
de la chine continentale et de monsieur
wrong pas retraités hong kong est tous
vivent dans moins de deux mètres carrés
au fil des ans ils sont devenus des
hommes grenier dans ces minuscules
logement
on trouve tous les précaires de hong
kong
des chômeurs sans indemnités des
personnes âgées sans retraite ou encore
de jeunes travailleurs migrants dans le
quartier de chams wipo il est des
centaines d'immeubles comme celui ci si
julio est femme de ménage dans une
maison de retraite avant d'arriver à
hong kong il ya trois ans elle a
travaillé comme ouvrière dans une usine
de jouets en chine
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue
c'est ici que nous vivons j'habitais
avec mon fils et c'est tout petit mon
fils et moi nous vivons sur le lit en
bas et là haut c'est pour les rangements
pour les affaires dont on ne se sert pas
en ce moment comme les affaires d'hiver
des couvertures et emballé ici ce sont
des choix de mon fils la vaisselle et
les ustensiles de cuisine c'est vraiment
petit don couloir il y a dix neuf
locataires comme si l ue les pièces d'à
peine deux mètres carrés sont empilés
l'une au dessus de l'autre ceux qui
habitent en eau de rembrandt et une
échelle pour accéder à leurs placards si
audio et son fils eux vivent dans une
pièce située en bas
soan après c'est difficile de vous
décrire ce que c'est de vivre ici
beaucoup d'inconvénients
nous sommes très nombreux et en été il
fait très chaud défi comment se
partagent tout on est obligé de faire
est que pour aller aux toilettes
pour ce faire la cuisine
[Musique]
les jo lui vit dans ce même couloir
chez lui c'est en haut de l'échelle dans
un grenier encore plus petit que celui
de sir hugh et son fils
on ne peut même pas s'y allonger
pendant la journée lydie où travaille
comme manutentionnaire chez un fabricant
d'électroménager
[Musique]
j'ai jamais imaginé quand j'étais en
chine que je pourrais vivre dans une
seule pièce
et même si c'est des conditions de vie
difficiles je suis bien obligé de les
accepter
[Musique]
les propriétaires sont invisibles
ce sont des marchands de sommeil sans
scrupules
on
monsieur longue vie au huitième étage
d'un vieil immeuble sans ascenseur son
appartement n'est pas compartimentée
comme celui de sir hugh de simples lits
superposés
autrefois grillage et servent de
logements à chacun des dix colocataires
malades des bronches
monsieur longue touche une pension
d'invalidité de 200 euros par mois avant
de tomber malade
monsieur wang a vécu de petits boulots
en petits boulots agents de sécurité
vendeur de légumes et réparateurs de
bicyclettes aujourd'hui ses colocataires
sont comme lui tous au chômage
actuellement un kong
c'est un monde qui est fait pour les
personnes riches même les gens de classe
moyenne ont du mal à acheter un petit
appartement et après leur crédit c'était
mieux au tour des anglais
xiao yu a atterri ici parce que son
salaire d'à peine 600 euros par mois ne
lui permet pas de louer autre chose
une annonce collé sur un mur dans le
quartier de chams wipo il n'en faut pas
plus à hong kong pour trouver un placard
de deux mètres carrés je paye mon loyer
enfin moi en général ça se passe comme
ça fait c'est très simple à la fin du
mois je paye le loyer au propriétaire tu
me donnes un reçu il n'y a pas de
contrat signé et il n'ya pas caution à
payer non plus les cahots laquelle
desailly et d'asséner mais ça se passe
bien on a de bonnes relations
si l ue à négocier avec son propriétaire
pour ne payer que 50 euros par mois
parce qu'elle fait le ménage des parties
communes
pour les autres locataires le prix du
loyer s'élève à 100 euros comment est ce
possible de cohabiter dans un espace
aussi étriqué
[Musique]
l'été la température était étouffante le
thermomètre monte régulièrement au
dessus des 30 degrés l'air est plombé
par l'humidité les puces sont partout
beaucoup installe un petit ventilateur
dans un coin de leur pièce
mais rien n'y fait raconte lee joo la
chaleur est insoutenable
dans les appartements grenier il n'y a
pas de place pour l'intimité
il faut apprendre à tout partager la
cuisine la douche et les toilettes pour
19 personnes mais aussi les odeurs ou
les relations utiles parfois la colère
éclate pour un simple vol casse et
chacun essaie de se faire tout petits de
trouver sa place au milieu de cette
promiscuité de trouver un espace à soi
la bénévole
je me sens pas concerné par la vie des
autres savoir s'ils sont célibataires
tous les jours je travaille
et quand je rentre je suis fatigué de
temps je le passe avec mon fils j'essaie
de l'aider à faire cette fois ci je peux
sans que j'aie eue avec le père de mon
fils m'a brisé le coeur
alors la vie des autres intimes ou pas
ça ne me concerne pas vous savez à cet
étage il n'y a pratiquement que des
célibataires depuis que j'habite ici
j'ai seulement vu une petite amie venir
une fois ci audio et simone ne
connaissent pas lee joo le
manutentionnaire ils vivent pourtant
dans le même couloir partagent la même
cuisine les mêmes toilettes mais ils
n'ont aucun endroit pour s'asseoir et se
rencontrer tout est trop exigu pour
créer l'amitié dans le couloir li jun a
sympathisé qu'avec son voisin du dessous
[Musique]
l'étroitesse et la promiscuité des
greniers impose la solitude
monsieur wrong vite ici avec pour seul
compagnon
les chats d'une amie qui lui rend visite
de temps en temps sa famille est
installée à hong kong mais n'a pas les
moyens de l'aider à 59 ans et après
treize années à vivre comme un homme
grenier monsieur wrong et fataliste
[Musique]
il ya une salle de bains par là aussi
lave à l'eau froide ont trouvé avoir de
l'eau chaude faut payer 4 dollars hong
kong et à son propriétaire
parce qu'on utilise son chauffe-eau donc
j'ai pris l'habitude de me laver à l'eau
froide
[Musique]
que faire de son temps libre
quand on vit dans deux mètres carrés la
plupart des hommes grenier ont un
téléviseur et certains passent leur
week-end devant en réalité la vie des
hommes grenier est polarisée par le
travail et le manque d'argent
si au lieu ne peut pas s'offrir un
ticket de métro faute de moyens elle
marche lorsque nous l'avons rencontré
elle n'était jamais allé voir la baie de
hong kong nous l'avons emmené prendre le
ferry avec son fils saimone
[Musique]
quand je ne travaille pas je sors avec
mon fils va se balader dans les centres
commerciaux au parc on fait de la
balançoire
parfois c'est lui qui me pousse et c'est
vraiment amusant centre commercial il y
a beaucoup de joie dans les magasins je
ne peux jamais lui en acheter alors il
boude
mais bon c'est comme ça quand on est
fatigué on rentre à la maison je veux
qu'il révise ses devoirs dans notre
chambre sauf parfois où il avait fromage
dehors
[Musique]
le mcdo c'est le luxe des loisirs pour
les plus modestes de hong kong
il y en a un à chaque coin de rue c'est
climatisé et on y mange pour moins de 2
euros
c'est la principale distraction de
saimone
pour monsieur wrong le big mac c'est
encore trop cher
il passe son temps libre dans les petits
squares coincé entre les tours il reste
assis sur un banc trois heures chaque
jour
c'est le seul endroit dit il où il
trouve un peu de sérénité
j'aime bien venir ici parce que ses
cales et que de toute façon je vois pas
où vous pourrez aller ailleurs je viens
ici pour lire mon journal et tuer le
temps
un logement plus grand
et surtout à soi
c'est évidemment ce à quoi aspirent les
hommes grenier pour moi le hlm c'est un
rêve de toute façon je ne peux pas rêver
d'autre chose quand même acheté un
appartement
mon fils me demande tout le temps si
j'ai des nouvelles pour notre demande de
hlm
et si nous allons arrêter de devoir
partager avec tout le monde pour enfin
être indépendant à hong kong
du fait des prix exorbitants de
l'immobilier privé la moitié de la
population vit en hlm
mais il faut des années pour obtenir un
appartement publics sea of view et son
fils devront donc cohabiter dans leur
grenier encore quelque temps comme
l'idiot quant à monsieur wrong
l'immeuble dans lequel il vit sera
bientôt détruit à la faveur d'une tour
moderne ou pourra-t-il se reloger
lui-même n'en n'a encore aucune idée
[Musique]